[Music]
components are like the LEGO pieces of
an angular application if you don't know
how to put them together properly you're
not going to be able to build anything
cool over the next 10 minutes or so I'll
show you all of the basics and angular
components and how to piece them
together in an application
this video is beginner level so if you
know a little bit about JavaScript and
web development you should be okay if
you're new to the channel make sure to
LIKE and subscribe and grab the full
write-up from angular firebase com the
first question we need to answer is what
is a component in the first place and I
think the most simple answer to this
question is that it's just a controller
for the user interface as a developer
you write components to control how your
app is experienced by end-users to show
you this in practice I'm opening a brand
new angular 6 app that was generated
with the CLI then I'm generating a new
component called home which you'll
notice creates four different files in
the app directory the vast majority of
the logic that you'll write will be in
the home component ES file the component
itself is just a typescript class but it
uses this component decorator to
sprinkle in some angular magic the most
important thing is that it allows us to
bind data from this typescript file to
the HTML template the first thing I want
to show you is how to bind typescript
code to your HTML let's define a
property on this class called clicked
that defaults to false now let's go into
the HTML and let's imagine we have a
button that we want to disable after
it's been clicked we combined our
typescript data to this attribute in
HTML by wrapping it in square brackets
disabled isn't something angular
provides it's an actual attribute on the
HTML element which I'm looking at here
in the Mozilla documentation the special
thing about angular is that we can wrap
this attribute in square brackets and
then bind it to our type script so
instead of just passing it a boolean
value like false we can actually pass it
our clicked property which we can then
toggle on our typescript as needed it's
currently set to false so we should be
able to serve our app and the button
should be clickable which it is if we go
into typescript and change our clicked
property to true you'll see that the
button is now disabled and unclick Abul
in addition to attributes we can also
bind to events that happen in the HTML
so let's say we want to change this
two disabled after it's been clicked
once we can use parentheses to bind to
the click event on this button and then
we'll pass it a function that will
define in our typescript to handle this
event now we can switch back to
typescript and define this event handler
method we currently have the clicked
property set to false but we want to set
that to true once the button is clicked
which we can do by calling this clicked
equals true when we click the button
this handle or will fire and in the
button becomes disabled because it flips
that property to true that's how you
bind to events and attributes in angular
but one other fundamental thing is
interpolation and basically all that
means is we're taking a raw value from
our typescript and rendering it out in
the HTML so for example let's say we
have the title here that shows the
angular version that we're currently
running so the title is just a string
value that gets created dynamically and
then we can go into our HTML and use the
handle bar syntax to interpolate it into
the template if we reload the browser it
should show us that we're running in
angular 6 for this project so now that
we have a working component how do we
actually use it within the context of
our angular application the most basic
way is to declare it in the HTML with
its selector which in this case is just
app - home if we go into this project's
app component we can just declare our
app home page there and it will be
rendered out like it's just a regular
HTML element but we can also load it
with the router and have it appear where
this router outlet is based on a certain
URL path check out episode 113 to learn
all about the router but the most basic
use case is that we setup a path and
then we point this path to our component
if we reload the app in the browser
you'll see it looks exactly the same but
if we open the augury plug-in and go to
the router tree you can see that it's
being loaded by the router instead of
just the HTML directly you can also load
components dynamically but without
changing the route a common use case
would be like a pop-up or a modal window
this technique is used frequently in the
ionic framework for example the alerts
controller will dynamically load an
entry component whenever the button is
clicked and lastly the cool new way to
load a component is with angular
elements which allows you to convert it
to a regular web component and then use
it outside of angular completely so you
could just drop it into a regular HT
mell page which you can learn all about
an episode 102 the next thing we're
going to look at our directives and a
directive is basically just like a
component but without its own HTML or
CSS instead it attaches to a host
element and changes the behavior of it
to demonstrate this I've added an object
called boat with some dummy data to our
component then perhaps the most useful
built in directive and angular is ng-if
and any directive that starts with a
star means it's a structural directive
and controls how elements are rendered
in the Dom in this case we're attaching
an NG F to a div and it will only render
this div if the right-hand side resolves
to true so going back to our clicks
property we're only going to show this
boat data if the button has been clicked
when we open the app you can see that it
looks just like it did before but when
we click the button it displays our boat
data you'll end up using ng F all the
time and angular and there's one other
directive that you'll use very
frequently as well which is ng 4 you can
use it to loop over an array of data so
let's imagine we have an array with
multiple boats in it
we've already mapped out how we want
each boat to be displayed but instead of
using ng if here we can replace it with
ng 4 then we'll iterate over the boats
array by saying let boat of boats then
the div that this directive is attached
to will be rendered for each item in
that array if we open the app you can
see we now have multiple boats utilizing
the same presentation logic so those are
super powerful but another thing you
often want to do is display different
CSS classes conditionally based on some
logic in your type script just as a
basic example let's imagine we have a
green and red CSS class we can use the
ng class directive to control which CSS
class gets applied to the h1 title based
on the name of the boat so we'll pass
the directive and object where the
left-hand side of each object property
is the CSS class we want to apply then
the value or the right side is an
expression that resolves to true or
false which in this case will either be
boat name equals Starfire or boat name
equals Oracle now we get a different
color for each title based on this logic
so far we've only looked at built in
directives in angular but you can also
build your own custom directives let's
go ahead and build our own with the
angular
CLI by running an ng generate directive
which we'll call magnifier that will
increase the size of an image when it's
hovered over overall this looks pretty
similar to a component but the key
difference is that there is no HTML
template or CSS styles instead it's used
as an attribute on an HTML element this
particular directive will be used to
modify the width of an image element so
we can bind to the host elements width
by using the host binding decorator then
any image that uses this directive will
start with a width of 200 then we also
want to listen to the mouse enter event
to know when the user is hovered over
the image with their mouse with that we
can use the host listener decorator pass
in the Dom event that we want to listen
to and then define a function to handle
this event in this case what we want to
do is really simple just increase the
width from 200 to 300 now we'll switch
back to the HTML in our component and we
currently have an image in there that
displays the boat image with a width of
200 let's go ahead and take this out and
replace it with the app magnifier
directive if we go back to our app and
hover over the images you'll see that
they're resized as soon as we hover over
them not the most useful thing in the
world but you get the idea of how you
can use components and directives
together to write really dry reusable
code there's another mechanism in
angular that helps us write reusable
code called pipes a pipe is always used
in an interpolated value in the HTML so
let's imagine we have a big number here
we can use the built in number pipe to
round this down to 3 decimals angular
has some useful built in pipes but the
real power comes when you start building
your own custom pipes and chances are
somebody's already written the code that
you need for your use case so make sure
to check out the angular pipes of github
repo for a full list of examples there's
one really special pipe that I want to
talk about now which is the async pipe
in web application you're commonly
fetching data asynchronously as a
promise or an observable and the async
pipe allows you to do this automatically
in a predictable way directly in the
HTML in this example I'm converting our
boats array into an observable by using
the rxjs of method so now it becomes an
observable object so our regular ng for
loop isn't going to work what we can do
is simply add the async pipe to our for
loop and now it's going to convert that
observable to an array by subscribing to
it and in addition it also unsubscribes
when this component is destroyed that's
a whole nother subject on rxjs
but just know that it's a very useful
mechanism for simplifying your angular
code in a real app we'd probably be
fetching these boats asynchronously from
a database and the async pipe allows us
to treat them more like a synchronous
plain JavaScript array at its core a
pipe is very simple it's just a function
that takes in a value and then spits out
another value each of our boats has a
year property on it let's say we want to
only display the last two digits in that
four-digit year all we have to do is go
into our custom pipe and then implement
this transform method the value
represents whatever value is inside the
handlebar syntax in your HTML then the
value you return is what you want to be
shown in the HTML in this case we'll
convert the number to a string and then
grab the last two elements on that
string then we can go add it to the boat
year and our HTML and then if we reopen
the app we'll see that we only get the
last two numbers on the year so now that
you know a lot about components pipes
and directives I want to talk about a
concept that's really important for
angular developers and that's never
touched the Dom if you're an experienced
JavaScript developer you're probably
used to doing something like this where
you call document query selector then
grab some element in the Dom and change
its inner HTML and when you're building
a progressive web app this code will
work perfectly fine because the Dom
exists in a web app but if you write
code like this and you ever want to do
server-side rendering or build a native
mobile app this code will not work
because the Dom does not exist on other
platforms so now you know why the use of
libraries like jQuery are generally
discouraged in angular now let's switch
gears into the component lifecycle a
component is just a class so the very
first thing that happen in its lifecycle
is the constructor aspired but
components have relationships with other
components and they have bindings that
are initialized in the HTML so things
get a little bit more complex in angular
you typically don't do anything in the
constructor except add your dependencies
and that's because your property
bindings aren't guaranteed to be
available until you run ng on it knit
which is the first time change detection
runs in this component so the uninit
lifecycle hook is where you do all of
your setup maybe you're fetching
from an API or you're setting up a
reactive form or something along those
lines I'll go ahead and add our boats
observable to energy on an it just to
simulate it coming from a database or
API the very last thing to happen to a
component is that it's destroyed which
triggers the on destroyed lifecycle hook
this is where you do any teardown for
your component and angular that is
commonly unsubscribing from an
observable to prevent things like memory
leaks and performance issues on an it is
by far the most common hook that you'll
use but if you have child views inside
of your component you might also want to
use after view in it which will ensure
that your child views are loaded as well
now that segues into a really important
concept in angular which is change
detection behind the scenes angular is
using something called zone j s that
will listen for any events or
asynchronous activity in your app and
then re render components as needed you
can determine when change detection is
happening by using this do check
lifecycle hook you wouldn't normally use
this to do anything significant but it
is useful for debugging at times if
you're building an interactive app this
lifecycle hook will be triggered
constantly you can see we get the first
console log when the component is
initialized that's when the ng on an it
lifecycle hook runs and then as we hover
around different events take place and
that triggers change detection and the
console log in the browser so now I want
to segue into a concept that is also
common in other JavaScript frameworks
like react in view and that smart
components versus dumb components or
also commonly called stateful versus
stateless or container versus
presentational and basically all this
boils down to is a separation of
concerns to make your code predictable a
smart component is generally a page or
container that controls how things work
throughout the app well the dumb
component is only concerned with
presentation logic I have generated a
new component called boat that will be
our dumb component it's going to take
the data from this ng for loop and
extract it into its own isolated
presentational component this allows the
parent component to focus on more
low-level things like synchronizing the
state of the app and fetching the items
from the database as your app grows in
complexity this just becomes an easier
way to rationalize what's happening in
so the home component is a container
that fetches the data while the boat
component is only concerned with
presenting the data in the UI there's a
ton of other things we can talk about
with angular components but many of
those you'll see in practice as we build
out different features on this channel
I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want to
build more advanced real world features
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase comm you'll get
exclusive pro videos every week plus a
copy of the angular firebase Survival
Guide thanks for watching and I'll talk
to you soon